for more on the war we are joined Now by
John Kirby he is the coordinator for
strategic Communications at the National
Security Council at the White House also
retired Admiral in the U.S Navy Admiral
Kirby good morning thank you for being
here uh we we've seen strikes on
civilians uh strikes on women and
children and now we are confronting the
possibility of a deep humanitarian
crisis people freezing to death going
without water there's a perennial
question for white houses like yours is
there a line here or are we just going
to let people suffer
well we're going to continue to make
sure we're supporting Ukraine as best we
can the United States is the largest
contributor of Financial and economic
assistance for humanitarian purposes
like this to Ukraine we're also the
largest contributor of security
assistants now 17 billion dollars worth
of weapons and capabilities to allow
them to continue to defend their
territory into some and to take some of
those towns and Villages back and
they're very much in the fight right now
both in the East and the South and we're
going to do everything we can to make
sure that they can stay in that fight
we are the largest contributor and I
want to get to the money question in a
moment but is there a line or a Zone a
way of thinking where the U.S intervenes
in a deeper way than it is currently not
just money not just arms there's
obviously the president's been very
clear we're not going to put U.S troops
on the ground to fight in Ukraine uh we
are going to do everything we can as we
have now for going on eight months to
make sure that the Ukrainian armed
forces have what they need in the field
and that just isn't coming from the
United States we're also leading
literally leading and coordinating
International efforts to get additional
weapons and capabilities into their
hands sometimes in in many cases
capabilities that they know better and
can use faster than even the ones that
we're providing from our own stocks so
we're going to stay at this you've heard
the president talk about that as long as
it takes we're committed to that as long
as it takes so let's talk about the
money uh component on the subject of as
long as it takes by our count it's
nearly 100 billion dollars in Aid to
Ukraine I know we're not the only
country kicking in but at a time when
there are a lot of taxpayer needs here
is there a line for the White House
where you're not going to spend taxpayer
money there we have had great support
from both sides of the aisle in Congress
over the course of the last eight months
uh terrific support I think everybody
realizes what's at stake here which is
more than just uh you know the town of
Curson or harkiv or slovians it's really
about this idea of sovereignty and it's
really about what the security
environment in Europe is going to look
like going forward it has changed today
and and it it affects the United States
and our national security interests
because so many of our allies and
partners are now in a different security
footprint than they were before we have
20 000 more troops on the European
continent now than we did you know again
nine nine months ago eight months ago so
we are we're working this very very hard
uh and we're going to stay at it uh
Admiral the House GOP leader Kevin
McCarthy on the subject of support from
Congress he said if the Republicans take
control they're not going to write a
blank check for Ukraine uh in the new
year is he going to get a phone call
from you today this has not been about
writing blank checks for Ukraine this
has been about bipartisan support in
Congress to continue to make sure that
Ukraine can defend itself and it can
stand up for its sovereignty because
that's really what's at stake here aside
of course from the literally hundreds of
thousands of Ukrainian lives that that
have been affected by by this war so
we've had great support we're going to
continue to work hand in glove with
Congress going forward for additional
financial support for Ukraine and we're
confident that we're going to be able to
to work with them to that to that end
all right Admiral Kirby thank you very
much my pleasure